Hey y'all! In today's video, I'll be showing you how to contour...
...even if you're a beginner.
First step, I'll be using the TruBlend Contour Palette to contour my face.
I'll be starting out with this darker color here to go ahead and imitate shadow.
So, the reason why we like to contour our faces...
...is just to give you a more chiseled and lean look to your face.
So, adding it to my forehead here, to my cheekbones, a little bit to my nose,...
...I added contour wherever I want to create shadow.
Okay, now blend.
I like to actually moisten this sponge before I blend...
...and it just helps kinda spread the product out a little bit more evenly.
And what I like a lot about this product is that it's oil-free but it's super creamy...
...so you can blend really nicely without putting a lot of effort into it.
I'm gonna take this golden color and start putting it on my cheekbones...
...and anywhere  that I want to project my facial features out.
So, anywhere that I see the natural light hitting my face,...
...that's where I'm gonna put my highlight.
Again, highlighting meaning going to attract light...
...to those different parts of your face.
Step number three is going to be using our medium brown...
...to create some transition from our highlight to our contour.
So, it's gonna warm up our face just a bit.
Step number four is going to be setting your face with a powder.
So, I'm going to be using the Queen Collection Matte pressed powder...
...to set all over.
This is gonna make my makeup last.